now each night we're going to update you
with the latest facts without fear
including information you're not gonna
get from a very biased mob in the media
and they're sick they're ugly twisted
world is pandemic they are using it
nothing more than another opportunity to
do what they do every day and that's
past president Trump how many times have
I said if he cured cancer they
criticized him for that I think I've
been proven correct unfortunately now
misery seems to love company joyless
Behar tried to get California governor
Gavin Newsom to say bad things about the
president unfortunately for joyless it
did not go as planned take a look do you
feel like you have to feed this guy's
ego to get the respirators and to get
the pee Pease is that what's going on
all I can say is from my perspective the
relationship has been strong and I'm not
doing it to kiss the ring I'm not doing
it in a way you know that and just being
forthright with the president he returns
calls he reaches out he's been proactive
we got that mercy ship down here in Los
Angeles that was directly because he
sent it down here everything by the way
there's a lesson there for Andrew Cuomo
you know what Andrew president's given
you those hospitals would take photo ops
in front of yeah he's been building all
the things that though you didn't do
yourself
governor Newsom by the way is a far left
Democrat he has about 68 lawsuits I
think he said it's pending against the
Trump administration arleigh fan of
Donald Trump but he's working together
and he's leading his state and making it
more safe and secure that a much better
job than they've done in New York I'll
tell you that and he's telling the truth
putting partisan politics aside he
should be commended tonight Cuomo on the
other hand he's been complaining each
and every day and sure he's going to
show up for a photo outfit let's see on
the Javits Center hospital that Donald
Trump and the federal government
constructed the Army Corps of engineer
he's accepting thousands of ventilators
many threw in a warehouse millions of
masks and gowns and yeah go around on TV
and you take a photo op in front of the
ship the comfort that by the way only at
twenty people today I'm not sure why and
bash the administration and demanding
they do their job just today tweeting we
do not have enough ventilators period
so how many ventilators is cuomo short
he does realize there are fifty other
states that are dealing with the virus
now today during his daily briefing the
president addressed this very issue
let's take a look they should have had
more ventilators they were totally under
serviced we are trying to do we're doing
our best for New York you know we have
we have States we have a lot of states
we have territories too but we have a
lot of states that have to be taken care
of some much more so than others we've
worked very well with the governor we
happen to think that he's well served
with ventilators we're gonna find out
but we have other states to take care of
every New Yorker needs to know what an
epic fail Governor Cuomo has failed the
state of New York on a honest a terrible
level after all November 2015 he was
given will show you the report an
important report from New York State's
Health Department Department of Health
let me read from page 30 it says quote
during a severe influenza pandemic there
is likely to be a projected shortfall of
ventilators fifteen thousand seven
hundred and eighty-three during peak
week the man after reading this report
Cuomo he purchased zero ventilators for
New York by the way smallest
geographical location with 11 million
people New York City instead he
instructed the Commission to figure out
ways to ration the existing 2,000
ventilators the number one target of
terrorism the number one at-risk place
in the country for disease the most
dense population has a shortage of
ventilators he wouldn't buy them but he
wasted 750 million on a solar project
another 600 million on another idiotic
project 90 million dollars on an island
all light bulb project and he wouldn't
buy the ventilators now because of an
executive order also in New York any
prescription of the potentially
life-saving treatment hydroxychloroquine
if you want it well you you got to go to
the hospital system which is already
overrun so in other words you can't have
your doctor call
a pharmacy in consultation with the
doctor he won't let that happen and
Cuomo why I thought you're pro-choice
governor let America let New Yorkers in
consultation with their doctors decide
the president when you ask him like
every other time he's building you
hospitals all over the place
sending you thousands of ventilators
bailing you out I'm sure he'll send you
the hydroxychloroquine just ask instead
he goes out on TV pounds his chest all
talk all talk no action blames the
president and his own health department
told him to buy them he refused he
wasted hundreds and hundreds and even
billions of dollars a mob in the media
oh they loved Governor Cuomo he treat
him like he's a hero well he failed the
people of New York and he treats the
president like garbage in the middle of
a national crisis there are there are no
help to the American people none how did
you not prepare the number one target of
terror unbelievable president you know
what it's all over the media as we now
go through and a lot of the media mob it
so different ways and you know you watch
our morning media what they say over
there fake news Don Lemon saying his
crap all over we won't go to that but
believe it or not Don Lemon pretends to
be a news anchor over there and if you
were an actual journalist this was an
actual news organization and he wasn't a
partisan hacked and they didn't have a
leftist agenda
well when his fake news network was
obsessed with the impeachment witch-hunt
the federal government was warning
Americans about coronavirus here's the
timeline December 27th Chinese officials
world health organization oh they saw
that there was some type of pneumonia
looking like virus they didn't know what
it was called yet people were getting
sick December 30th that's when they
first found out a few days later January
6th the federal government started issue
warnings wasn't labeled corona till
January 7th follow these dates January
20 CDC its Emergency Operations Center
January 31st ten days after the first
known US case president Trump issued
that travel ban and conducted a
mandatory quarantine followed look at
your screen every step of the way the
administration took unprecedented
aggressive action and
the crap kicked out of it racist
xenophobic hysterical fear-mongering
think about it this way dr. Anthony foul
he served six presidents this guy has
been a champion fighting pandemics and
HIV and I mean that highly respected and
you know one of the most trusted experts
in the field dr. foutch II didn't
realize the true threat of the virus on
January 21st take a look
bottom line we don't have to worry about
this one right well I you know obviously
need to take it seriously and do the
kinds of things that the CDC and the
Department of Homeland Security are
doing but this is not a major threat for
the people in the United States and this
is not something that the citizens of
the United States right now should be
worried about
but very well respected not to say
anything bad about dr. pouchy he was
lied to by the by the Chinese government
20 January 26 take a look the American
people should not be worried or
frightened by this it's a very very low
risk to the United States but it's
something that we as public health
officials need to take very seriously
where's the vice and five days later
President Trump enacted travel ban Wow
how much force would this all be now get
this just breaking tonight yeah the ever
so clueless out-of-touch quid pro quo
Joe remember him is you know running
those bad podcasts and his TV podcast
initially called the banned xenophobic
hysterical and fear-mongering look at
this news yep Joe Biden now supports the
president's travel ban with China that's
two months and three days too late Joe
now every Democrat running for office
needs to be asked the same question you
people in the mob and the media ask him
now in retrospect was Donald Trump right
this was bold this was unprecedented
untold thousands of Americans didn't
contract the virus and many others
didn't die and China lied to the world
that's why doctor foul she didn't know
it's not his fault but still the
president got it right five days later
they lied about the number of cases the
amount of death the way the disease is
spread they blocked
less researchers world researchers
important data the World Health
Organization spread their lies and
propaganda they're a disgrace we
shouldn't have nothing to do with them
down the line one study in the u.s.
found if China had been been honest
sooner that study 95% of all of this
could have been prevented the mob and
the media don't care about truth they're
just worried about scoring cheap
political points as demonstrated by fake
news Acosta today take a look and where
is dr. pouchy
I don't know but every time you ask that
question whenever he's not here you look
you say where is he and you'll say is
there a problem no problem whatsoever
every time he's not here sometimes I'll
ask him to come because that's the first
question that you and a couple of others
from the fake news establishment ask is
where stalked fhe we're doing great